is part of you hesitant to describe the
the movement uh in words um
because it's changing all the time or do
you feel like if you write it all down
in words of what we are
then you can't actually be what it is
words are not a good container for these
ideas
yeah i'm not hesitant i'm reluctant
it's uh yeah it's it's not good enough
it's movement is a cloud and it's
something that
you cannot find its limit it's it's it's
a fog
floating around and uh
yeah it's it's not something that we can
define so easily
what i do is i use what i call my slice
and dice approach
i i slice it and i dice it through
multiple perspectives until i get
the most tiny piece out of the slicing
and dicing that i can observe and look
at
but even that of course misses the point
you know it's just an attempt
to map the cloud somehow a little bit
to know something about it yeah words
are problematic
and like i said we change words we abuse
them you know if you're going to use
movement for something else and you you
have a huge following
you abused my work and now i have to
change my word because i don't want to
be connected to that
so look at what happens to brazilian jiu
jitsu
yeah all of a sudden there was a
separation there
machado jiu-jitsu gracie jiu-jitsu they
didn't they didn't want to belong
anymore just under this big title of
brazilian jiu-jitsu people took their
word
which they they in the beginning used
and yeah abused it
in their eyes or used it in other eyes
yeah so movement is is not to be
captured you try to hug it it disappears
you look at it too
you're zooming in too much it disappears
you have to respect that
you have to be humble about it and you
have to
embrace the concept fade your eyes a
little bit
peripheral vision let it exist let it
feed you
work with it in a smarter way